the leather look is deceptive the fabric
used to make these fashion products is
purely plant-based it comes from the
fibers of pineapple leaves and weighs
just a quarter of what real leather
would British designer Alicia Lai has
been using this innovative natural
material in her shoe collections for
about a year now although it is a
natural product it actually looks really
very stylish it's got a natural texture
to it
it comes in several different colors and
it's nice and soft and pliable it's easy
to take care of and durable the fabric
made from pineapple fibers is called
Pina tex and is made by the british
startup on an us annum
its founder Kaminey whoreson of spain
spent about a decade developing the
material before that she worked in the
leather industry for 15 years while
looking for a sustainable alternative to
leather she experimented with banana and
agave leaves before she found pineapple
this particular pineapple fiber which is
being used in the Philippines for 400
years traditionally to make very
beautiful very light textiles and I
realized and the quality of this fiber
because it's very very fine but it's
very soft and flexible but also strong
waste from the pineapple harvest on the
Philippines provides the raw material
farmers collect the leaves and separate
the fibers using a special machine then
the fibers are dried in the Sun from
then a Filipino factory produces a
nonwoven fleece like material which is
coated with polymers and bonding agents
to make the Pina text robust and long
lasting about 480 leaves go into each
square metre when I started to work with
the factory and they had never done
anything like it because they were used
to working they still work with
polyurethane you know petroleum-based
fibers which are very much much easier
that all even stronger and and it took
us a couple of years to come up to a
mesh that wasn't falling above two bits
in the meantime Pina Tex fulfills all
industry standards and is ready to go on
the market here in the pineapple room in
London several designers display their
products among them are the Spanish firm
maravilla bags
and the Australian clockmaking company
time for change well-known companies
like German sporting goods manufacturer
Puma are also experimenting with the
material and customers seem to like it
it comes from the earth and then it goes
back into the earth and it doesn't harm
anything in between so you know if no
chemicals are used when it's made it's
all completely natural so I think it's
great I think it's a fantastic idea
something that we're using as an
industry by-product or a weight that is
otherwise being burnt or sent into a
landfill to be made into shoes and bags
and wash straps
British fashion expert Allyson Louis
found the fabric unusual and it drew her
attention as an investor she observes
the fashion scene and support startups
that place special value on
sustainability change the whole shape of
the industry won't happen overnight but
in time it will and help these commuters
in all different countries and
developing countries become more
sustainable a lot of them are women find
it also helping how the women in these
communities so actually it's a really
long face all stages of the show under
Nazanin founder carmen eco sir wants to
continue expanding demand for her
pineapple leaf fabric already exceeds
what she can produce